you're putting yourself in front of so
many people's if I go on my dream shot
and yeah it might not work and yes and
when it doesn't work some people might
be like your son try again some people
get blocked everyone gets like a really
good idea of like I want to do something
so let me sit around watch a movie
listen to podcast like I want to do that
then they stop so I don't know how none
of the money money is a hurdle that's
kind of easy to get over to just hear
how simple it is sometimes you just need
somebody to be like it's this simple
dude and give you three steps and
suddenly you're like that's it I can
take it the rest of the way getting
started is always the hardest part if
you're here listen to me talk about this
stuff you are not a film fan your
filmmaker you just have made a film yet
go out and make your film he's an
American filmmaker actor comedian and
podcaster he rose to prominence for his
low-budget comedy film clerks in which
he acted directed and co-produced it
he's also known for his long humorous
Q&A sessions which are often filmed and
distributed for DVD release he's Kevin
Smith and here's my take on his top ten
rules to success rule number one is my
personal favorite I make sure to stick
around although to the end for some
special bonus clips also as Kevin is
talking if he says he'll send it really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below I put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well enjoy
[Music]
you can do what the fact that absolutely
and sometimes you'll have the expecting
the hope for results but there's so many
doors into the thing I'm not just
talking about well I'm talking about
everything and you're interested in life
there are so many doors that we all look
right at the front door and go how do we
get through there's a massive one go in
the back door
so the side window designed them are the
hole in the wall and you belong in the
room - you don't have to wait to be
invited into something you know I'm here
to tell you nobody will ever invite you
into something amazing because killed
ours if you want to be involved with
something and you want to see something
that doesn't exist
all you to do is try you're putting
yourself in front of so many people just
I go online see the shot and yet it
might not work and yes and when it does
work some people might feel a scary side
so try again that's it man that's all
we're here is sorry end of it there's no
winner feel God just fly right ride
every day before they stick me in the
grave and I'm not talking about moving
downs I thought about all that they said
they're going to do that one day you
look tomorrow do it right now just give
it a shot
because maybe it takes a day maybe it
takes a week maybe takes five years but
you don't get there without giving it
that first step and I get it first up
you know they say a journey my moms
giving us a single step what they don't
say
single step is harder than every other
model that comes after that all those
models are easy once you take that first
one but I understand what it's over this
bigger person said look at me I'm
shopping and I read every day don't be
fat you're going to die oh my god will
one day I might never take that first
step man and so I continue to be fast
no but in everything else
my I can't take that first step so I
know I'm talking about this bike ride
you give it a shot man don't worry what
you're saying I'm clear the mystery for
you will say everything dude you can
build up the cathedral and your people
will break the clouds and someone will
down below beyond you're doing it wrong
you like don't listen to those people
like moves forward and people that want
to tell you you suck are usually behind
you
keep moving forward and try every day
our first piece of advice don't ask
anybody for money man I'm looking at the
wrong place they'll never going to give
me a job I look at the monitor
I was playing to her I'm starting a
connection I'll post live I say you got
it
camera 1 all right don't go to people
for money man that you don't need that
much fun unless you're making some kind
underwater epic you don't need to go to
somebody else there are no more
gatekeepers I mean there are if you want
their money by all means but you got to
take their notes and stuff but you don't
have to wait for somebody to tell you
yes you may proceed you don't have to go
out there with your hand held out and
whatnot of course there's like IndieGoGo
Kickstarter you can raise a budget that
way and you're essentially not begging
for money or pre selling all your your
DVDs and whatnot in advance to help you
finance your dream but don't get that
thinking a kind of incorrect thinking
out of your head man you don't have to
wait or ask somebody or approach a
financier I you know I did on credit
cards bunch of credit cards that I can't
put together I always feel like the
Orman is dying and we're suddenly right
she said they're gone I said I was
starting my first gum pie but it's where
she goes I'm starting my first film but
I need money I'm like well then you're
not starting for some or you can't start
your first film without needing that
money at all some people get blocked
everyone gets like really good ideas
like I want to do something so let me
sit around watch a movie listen to
podcast like I want to do that then they
stop to logano have the money money is a
hurdle that's kind of easy to get over
particularly in the age of technology
with this magical box right here are the
ones we have in our pocket we'll shoot a
movie you can edit a movie you can
upload it to YouTube all from the same
device all within like an hour or
something like that so when that
technology is at your hands sometimes
people a little afraid about like well I
don't know how to use it or they say
that naked movies make my takes money
and of course it does takes a little bit
of lucre but not as much as like that
should stop somebody from going out to
finance their own dream or go out
looking for fine
but that's thing I try to curb like
don't ask people for money if you do
that then you just give yourself excuse
to never really take the next steps
really well I couldn't find the budget
like a lot of people ask me like I was
where you were once can't you help me
and I was like well the difference was
when I was where you were never asked
anybody for help I just did it myself
so it's always better if you can do
yourself you feel better at the end of
the day and then you're not bugging
anybody with your hand out y'all know
anybody nobody's got anything over you
and they're also not telling you like
hey you know that vision that you've
been carrying around your whole life
change it because there's something
about it that bugs me and since I'm
showing out the dough you got to do that
sort of thing
first time out especially dumping come
my hair looks terrible first time out
essentially don't don't go looking for
money from somebody else man especially
that first film of yours because you're
trying to get you out there the bit of
most you you'll ever have a chance to do
is when you're making your first flick
man if you've got a movie fan you've got
a movie maker like there's I've never
met a filmmaker that wasn't a movie buff
first I don't care who it is whether
it's like me or great directors like
Scorsese and Quentin Tarantino they're
hardcore movie fans who still imbibe so
I don't think it's possible to be a
filmmaker unless you're a film fan so I
always encourage everyone in those q and
A's where I'm like if you're here listen
to me talk about this stuff you are not
a film fan your filmmaker you just have
made of film yet go out and make your
film because who knows better how to do
this stuff than the pretty people that
consume it on a regular basis and you
know it's fine like the internet is a
distraction that allows people to
express themselves about movies you know
and you can be funny and crappy about
like crap on Lucifer but it pulls you
away from like there's no internet when
I started so I made a movie if the
internet existed i probably would've
commented on other people's movies but
because it didn't exist i was like well
let me try to make one of these movies
myself and now i live in a world where
people comment on it some largely I get
very wonderful things set and then I get
a bunch of people saying crappy things
as well but none of that exists without
me doing something first without me
making something so I always like to
tell that audience like we're not just
I was you i sat there watching other
people's stuff and I just got to a place
where I was like why them why not me
like if this counts as a movie why can't
I make a movie and stuff which is funny
because that's what my movies make
people do that like you know go this
counts I'm making a movie that's a good
call to arms on I'm not even insulted by
that am i good whatever makes you step
forward and try your self-expression
it's the only reason anyone knows my
name or my work and I've been doing this
for 20 years I've got to get a real job
is because it started with the first
step gone like why can't I do that you
know like I think people do it and
that's interesting I like their stories
but never saw my world represented up on
the screen and that's where I looked for
myself and ever found myself in a
classroom never found myself in the
church man closest moments I've ever had
to finding out who I am
they've been an art sitting in a movie
theater watching a movie man it's the
dark mirror you see yourself reflected
in a weird way in reading and listening
to music watching TV these are the
closest moments where I was like oh I
think this is who I am specially good so
that's that's within everybody
I've spent 21 years of my career chasing
a better career chasing somebody else's
career because that's all you have to go
by right you look at those who have gone
before you so my whole career I've
always aimed for a mark and constantly
missed it like never hit it so by my own
standards very unsuccessful but in the
process of doing that for 21 years which
I believe is 3 score for morning on one
more score and I'm Gettysburg if I if I
believe it the idea is over that time I
established what what it is that that I
do in my in my quest to be somebody else
like John Hughes to have the career of a
John Hughes I wound up having the career
of a Kevin Smith which to me is like
means whatever but oddly enough they're
a bunch of people are like I'll kill to
have your career and that's really weird
and wonderful so whenever you kind of
get a chance to sit down and talk to
those cats you just want to remind them
a you can have this career and like I
backed into and lucked into in a lot of
places but most of it is just
persistence and willingness to try
stupid a lot of people don't want to try
things that might not work you know this
guy never wants to try this
you're a thing and there is no such
thing as the sure thing and if you're
looking at somebody else's work to try
to gauge your own as I have for years
you will constantly feel like a failure
instead cost Trianon on telling your
story like this is the thing I'm real
big on your voice is your only currency
in this life that's all you got the
things you see and perceive the prism
through which you process all the
information that you take in as any of
the most unique supercomputer on the
planet unique from everybody on that
perspective is valuable insanely
valuable because nobody else can give it
but you and that's why it's always
better to shoot weird or shoot different
or shoot original as opposed to shoot
what works like or go for a successful
model or as I've tried to do try to be
John Hughes or something like that
you'll never succeed that way if you try
using your own voice you try expressing
your own thoughts that nobody else
because they're such a best shot at
success because that's the thing you
bring to the table but nobody else to
bring and if your timing is fantastic
you say the right thing at the right
time you could have a career so when you
get into this business they tend to like
tell you to shape it up and like take
off the edges and make it look like this
hey that work do that but always shoot
for that thing that you want to do I
remember all about and I'm involved
isn't that's important you can't shake
the pad like talk to hockey player and
then they'll say every goal in this and
we can remember one thing you remember
seeing this on and you know four
negative six is negative floats right
because it's kind of allowed to filter
dialog with ourselves about incredulity
or maybe I'm not good enough it allows
you to kind of like wallow and
self-esteem issues we rarely hear the
good you can't do it without programs
for it and I can't tell you how many
times people says wonderful things to me
and print in real life and I can hear
that I'm just listening to this [ __ ]
over here tell me I'm terrible I'm at my
job okay actually you know it sticks
with you you have to train yourself and
maybe if you're smart from the jump you
realize before you even start down the
path that it doesn't matter what anybody
says the game is always on your stick
I'm sorry very Tritan hired Hawking
metaphor in the melon the game is always
on your stick and nobody can take it off
and tell you differently as dudes in the
stands will tell you're doing it wrong
they will always tell you that because
critics are or people that know where
they're gone they still know how to drop
car and so of course they'll tell you
how to drop your knees then you step
away but don't listen to that I'm not
that always a great spiritual for you
I'm just saying no less than anybody
says it's all right he's like this like
the negative is going to be there
try to end of the positive and that's
something I really have to train and try
to do over my lifetime I don't know what
predisposed to hear and believe negative
and is it it's a nice thing to step up
and say beautiful things about the work
you do and
that's what you got to remember now it's
like being a room with this many people
who likes it there move on and see how
to they want to be there you know like
we show this movie in Sundance first
time and it was nice but one like this
because the Sun is you got a lot of
industry to feel like this
[Music]
amuse me hold it on exercise so you know
there you're going to counter LOC vanity
you can bench seating link you and
Anthony on it you let your eyes go
someplace else find them like cuz after
your plane and almost the Connie I do
regret how much time I wasted especially
now that I know I'm finishing like if
you look at the NFL is so many lot like
if I just day Hornish is this then
concentrated on creating rather than
whining bitching or something like that
I had some look so much more chill from
my career but don't let that trap your
mental I'm thanks
very often game we're gonna fish and you
know what there was absolutely right
everything makes every horrible thing
they say about your work absolutely
right they're not lying
that's how they feel but make sure you
listen to other people just a little bit
to say exactly what you want to know
exactly which is beg in here what you
dreamed about hearing when you broke
that one line years prior don't forget
to get them
we've spent so much time focusing on the
pictures of negative people give a lot
of sessions with people like it that's
why you're doing this while you're there
I'm not doing everybody else because I'm
just going to do what I want to do
because life's assured and I can't live
up to other people's expectations I can
only do what I can deliver in your foot
put that on my wrist to remind me all
times of like something in so you know I
will stuff them in a Polish let me talk
about anger to do so you know things up
but you can learn from that you know
there's no such thing as absolute
failure except sitting there and not
finding you know it's like that absolute
failure but even if you fail at
something Valentine is the best thing
did you learn how to do it better the
next time as long as you fly again
you're smarter than the average have
some people kind of try something you
falls apart now walk away there's a
bunch of cats who like I get it they
look at it like it's stupid why would
you waste your opportunities or
something they don't seem to think that
this is something given by others like
they still see it as like we've been
given an opportunity no nobody gave me
jack I want and created opportunity for
myself nobody ever shows up at your door
knocks and says hey man you want to tell
stories there's much money go
make-pretend I've never done that that
doesn't happen you got to make steps
toward that thing in the first place so
I spent a lot of time trying to explain
the people the difference between like
you know given an opportunity and
creating your world creating your own
opportunity because if you create your
own opportunities we hold and nobody
then people can't say things like you
shouldn't do this and like why as long
as I keep my budget slow make sure
everyone gets their money back and stuff
and do whatever goofy thing I wanted to
play right now I want to go to my grave
one day being like I should have made
the walrus movie and then drop god I
want to be the guy that's like can't
believe we made that long float and I'm
dropped by a little bit satisfied
because we're not talking about
reshaping the world or big important
issues then it's all micro not macro and
stuff it all begins kind of with you so
you know that's about belief you can't
expect a bunch of people out there to
believe you are this thing unless you be
this thing yourself we shot this flick
it's called tusks it stars this guy
Michael parks it was in this movie red
said I did three years ago Justin long
as the guy he turns into a walrus yeah
and
where to you now this all came from a
dopey podcast was going wouldn't it be
funny if it hands down the best thing
I've ever done and the whole ring I'm
not lying dude I know I usually say it
on every movie that I've made but I I
mean it like this movie looks beautiful
this is the movie that the guy who made
clerks dreamed about making because I
didn't want to make clerks like I
eventually make clerks but what I wanted
to make was David Lynch movies like I
loved how weird and wonderful David
Lynch was but I don't have enough talent
to do that I had enough talent to make
clerks 20 years later I have enough
talent to go for the things that I
dreamed about when I was a nascent
beginner and stuff and part of the
reason is like all right up your game
you know but see how far you can push it
but the other reason is I got a lot of
people who listen to me and watch me and
pay attention to the stuff I do you got
a captive audience man and what if you
want art in your life you want more
people experience what you've and all I
did was try like I had this idea about
making a movie setting it can be in
Stuart and I tried it and it worked and
life's been like blow jobs and Donuts
ever since right so you want to
encourage people to do that a woman by
the way yeah and not about that
Christian girlfriend and do you want to
encourage others to do that you want
others to kind of feel that I'm not
saying everyone's got to be filmmaker
we're going to make TV everyone's got to
write books but why not do a little like
you know people get in this mindset of
like we're the audience they're the
filmmakers and we'll watch and they'll
make anybody can do this crap I've spent
20 years trying to tell people like pick
up a camera it doesn't take much Podcast
makes it even more of a great equalizer
because that requires a cell phone a
laptop you sit down with your friends
your girlfriend your boyfriend your
mother I've sat down with my mother in
podcasters and you just talk anybody
could do that that doesn't take Talent
but on that podcast like there were so
many people on Twitter from that episode
talking about it was really interesting
to hear you guys building the idea like
I didn't know that's how it worked and
that grabbed me because that was me 20
years ago going how how do I get from
here to there and here it was we laid
them out a little bit on a blueprint on
the podcast you heard us creating a
story you heard me going like yeah you
could do this how simple it was is just
demystifying the process a little bit
and you do that it's kind of like a
clarion call to those out there going
look here how simple it is now like we
showed you how simple it was once to
make
courts with black-and-white movie pick
up a camera anybody can do this now with
like this episode this podcast that
turned into this movie touch it's this
blueprint for anybody for the kid for
the thirteen-year-old for the forty
five-year-old for the six-year-old
mother who's like I always wanted to
make a movie to just hear how simple it
is sometimes you just need somebody to
be like it's this simple dude and give
you three steps and suddenly you're like
that's it I can take it the rest of the
way getting started is always the
hardest part and that you've got a bunch
of people listening to you and it's nice
that the audience I'm glad they're there
to support me but I want to give it back
you want to support them you want to be
like as happy as I am you can do this
too as much as you like watching this
making it's even better like go do it so
this tough thing has been more about the
audience and oddly enough and not
thinking about my career my standing
where I stand the film community whether
I've grown as an artist I let go all
that stuff and all I thought about was
like I just want to inspire one kid to
pick up a camera and be like if that's
how you make a movie I want to do it too
I'm just trying to like secure my future
and watch good movies and the way to do
that is to show a bunch of people whose
voices are different than anything
you've ever heard before not the same
thing you see on TV or movies to show
them how simple it is to show them that
their voice is their currency the thing
that you have to say that special thing
that story you have to tell nobody else
can tell and you want to encourage
people to do that because that's all I
did people go oh you've been very
fortunate and what a great career out
the only thing is I one day sat there
watched enough movies and TV to be like
why not me like they're doing it like
what's the difference and it just took a
little bit of like slacker Richard
Linklater's film slacker demystify the
process so for me with Tuscan this
podcast and smart cast the episode that
birthed the movie in the old process of
the movie is just a long way of saying
here are your blueprints go do what I
did because it rocks how does one spend
so many plates at once well there's no
formula and to be honest with you it's
very dangerous pastime not as dangerous
a juggling chainsaws but you can tend to
get swamped by your own amount of
projects that you slope the amount of
boats that you float men could come back
turn around like a Royal Navy and sink
your fat ass so basically you got to
feel what's right for you man it helps
to have a wonderful support team around
you guys fantastic people in my life who
may not the least of which is that don't
shake it who make everything I do a lot
easier stuff I
with ideas I want to do this and other
people actually make it happen
implemented so that helps to have a team
you don't have a team you got to figure
out what that balance is for yourself
you can't take on too much but at the
same time you don't want to just do one
thing I like to spend a lot of plates
because you put all your eggs in one
basket don't work out you're bored
you've wasted all that time but the fact
of the matter is back in the day we used
to make a movie and then work on just
the movie and wait for the movie was out
and then figure out what to do next and
now you know it would lead sometimes to
like let's say you made your zero you
make the movie over the course of a
while it comes out and that's it it's
over like in a week or two weeks so I
like to spend as many plates as possible
that way like this thing in panning out
or this thing is too far off in the
distance or this ain't going to happen
the way I want it boom we can shift over
to something out so that's why I do it
but when you do be careful you got to
find the right balance I wish there was
a formula to give you there's not it's
all up to you it's inside of you just do
as much as you can before you get to the
point where like I can't a game or don't
kill yourself or art although we're
going to kill yourself or anything or it
would be the best reason we'd never kill
yourself in this life you're ever going
to kill yourself try being Batman first
and I go into the emergency room and I
was like Donald Smith and like I'm sorry
he passed they took me into the room as
my father laying on a gurney just dead
still has a tube sticking out of him and
they're trying to intubate him or
something like that but just motionless
quiet
no breathing whatsoever and it was weird
news I mean to say the least you always
know eventually parents going to go but
I wasn't ready I wasn't ready for that
moment and then I walked out and I went
outside not a cigarette I've still
cigarette smoker in those days and I was
just thinking about being half an orphan
or halfway to being an orphan or
something like that my brother comes out
and I was like I can't believe it right
he goes yeah it's pretty tough and I
said how was it because my brother was
there he was staying with my I thought
my parents and Donald without missing a
beat my brother goes dad died screaming
and I was like what and he goes dad died
screaming as what'd he mean like well he
woke up and he was kicking the [ __ ] off
and screaming about being on fire and he
was so hot and so hot and get him water
screaming the screaming got louder and
louder and it reached a fever pitch and
he died and I don't know how else to say
it but dad died screaming and that hit
me like a Mack truck and I remember
thinking oh my god in this world where
even a good man like my old man is going
to die screaming there's no point and
not trying to achieve every dream that I
have this is my eventual end one day
that's it
[Music]
and and I really felt like man that's
like I can't this is my future we're all
probably going to go out screaming so
the best thing to do prior to that is to
try to pack that life with as much
wonderfulness fun productivity surround
yourself with people that are going to
help you do that you know gives in this
world there's not a lot of support a lot
of negativity is a lot of cynicism even
as I sit here and tell that story about
my father dying I guarantee you there's
a cynical head in this house maybe more
sitting there going who cares move on
tell a joke the world is full of why man
you tell people something they'll tell
you why throw rock and you'll hit
somebody with wild like hey man I want
to make a movie why why do you think you
could do that why why nobody else is
doing it why are you doing it there's so
much why you go out and you find why not
you surround yourself with why not
people are just like why not we're like
hey man I'm going to try something like
I why not let's give it a shot people
will try to help you do your dreams make
your dreams come true and you do the
same for them we're all in this together
and it cost nothing to encourage an
artist that's why I get up here for
almost 20 years now after the movie man
a lot of filmmakers get up after the
movie and spend more time than the movie
itself talking but I've been trying to
impart one simple lesson for nearly 20
years anybody can do this you know what
I'm saying like I wasn't born into a
business or the film business or born
with a mic in my hands I have no
discernible talent whatsoever man I have
no connection to the business we're from
New Jersey and stuff I got lucky
somebody picked up the movie and boom I
was off and running
and part of that manifest when you're in
brought into the indie film community
part of your your job part of your honor
part of your privilege is to make sure
that keeps going to encourage other
people you know to tell people
it's worth the shot just like Wayne
Gretzky said like you miss a hundred
percent of the shots you never take it's
always worth the shot now if you're
talking about leg if what your shot is
like I've always wanted to kill 12
children Kevin don't take that shot at
all I'm not talking about that you know
I'm talking about
Archie you know writing a blog and
making some music making a movie making
a cupcake store in a knitting store
putting together of the YouTube clip
just anything that's just not all we
must do this because it's part of my job
or this will get money some you just do
just to see if it could be done live a
Whynot life man because we're all going
to die screaming so make sure when you
die screaming you're totally fulfilled
you like I took all the shots I did it I
did went after everything I wanted to or
at least tried
take the shot the shot is always worth
taking whether it's a dopey thing like
podcasting or writing a book or writing
a blog think about the encouragement you
get when you encourage an artist think
about the potential that comes out of it
you tell dude good job man that person
maybe one day writes that blog that you
mean out to the entire world
because it says exactly what you always
want to say but couldn't yourself or
they write that song that you play over
and over after a loved one dies because
it means the world to you that they make
that movie that is the one you cling to
when everything is going wrong in life
all you pop that in and things aren't
bad for two hours all that comes from
encouraging it artists nothing good
comes from discouraging an artist so for
20 years I keep coming up here and going
go out and do it why the [ __ ] aren't you
doing this it's so fun you should do it
take your shot I took my shot and it's
nothing but playing doughnut you know
just
so I'm here to tell you man give it a
shot go out and try
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because the next shot
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what did you learn today from Kevin
what is the less that's most immediately
applicable to your life or to your
business leave it down in the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to GU Rob jr. thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and making that funny
cartoon to go alongside it I really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
we weren't encouraged dreams so like now
I'm a-standing testimony to the
possibility of normalcy having
everything they want by simply heading
toward it like I have no talent no
discernible talent no abilities and
stuff like that but I've got will you
know I don't have skill I've been told
that it's only times a lot of critics
over and over I know that I don't have
skill but I will and will it take you a
lot farther man everyone is really do
you need coal and generators bottom
million first all that hopital and it
was mine Durban is and hit everybody he
did it but on a national chef or 22
years and anybody is honest and he is no
mater JIT office breath let Billy were
here come over here in here we're all on
together and we all had the answers to
each other's questions and problem we
should not be late one and the bees I do
that and it seemed on the stuff letters
in social media or something like that
which is better than one at a time until
this moves up tell people that happiness
research I'll navigate hothead hot
getting it is responsible absolutely on
end I carry way all that airs podcasting
is Brendan and having put it on your
phone sit down off the friends I'll pull
up one of your and often but then and I
can and pull your broadcast in down and
before the people that love you have a
squared world were me know what
everybody look like and suck air because
it will never forget anybody look like
when it got Bob would you know my first
any mood found their voice man and we
don't run around a recording
excessive use that the decision to top
Express is reading to sit down who are
the people who you love people like how
many hockey heroes la Muerta most
importantly good to happen yourself out
there but everybody know who you are and
share like August other than after years
I love it I promise you
Elvis press any way shape or form if I
absolutely do this at least lunch you
can have their share you all the people
it will happen so are the court your
honor paddling off the baggage baggage
Obama miliary time that the top is
talked to share eyelash logica what
happened about you today honey stay my
little very long habit of throwing on
every day may alter didn't everyone in
this room she make all the difference
with somebody else
yeah no and yet he is on dragging out
they did or s but all he did for a lot
more than that and like under Moskovitz
way or under baby I implore you all pull
out be too confident generative you are
Ellen story after being you
[Applause]